the city of Houston will celebrate the
life of former first lady barbara Bush
tonight City Hall was lit up in mrs.
Bush's favorite color blue overnight she
died Tuesday at her home in Houston
former President George HW Bush says in
a statement that the outpouring of love
and friendship being directed at the
enforcer is lifting us all up he was of
course quoting a family nickname for his
wife bianna golodryga isn't st. Martin's
Episcopal Church in Houston where mrs.
Bush's funeral will be held beyond a
good morning to you good morning Gail
you and I are both honoring the former
first lady wearing blue this morning I
can see and you know from the minute you
land at George Bush International
Airport you realize that the Bush family
in Houston go hand-in-hand as you
mentioned the private ceremony will be
taking place at this church st. Martin's
Church behind me here on Saturday among
those that will be attending first lady
Melania Trump the Obamas and the
Clintons from the Bush's summer compound
in Kennebunkport Maine to the gates of
their Houston home bouquets of flowers
honor the former first lady books
celebrate her dedication to literacy
mrs. Bush's children including her
eldest son's former President George W
Bush and former Florida Governor Jeb
Bush remember their mother with humor
they come up to you and they go I love
your mother and that was always code for
I'm a Democrat I can't stand you your
brother I had the joy of speaking to mom
the day she died and the day before she
died and the day before she died I said
mom I just want you to know you've been
a fabulous mother and I love you dearly
and she said I want you to know that
you're my favorite son on the phone
former first lady Laura Bush says her
mother-in-law was the strongest of
leaders and I couldn't talk about women
leaders without mentioning my
mother-in-law watching her I learned how
to be a first lady and I'm so grateful
for her example Charles Foster is a
longtime friend of the Bush family who
will be at Saturday's private service
it's going to be more of a celebration
of her life there's going to be I'm sure
some tears but also some laughter and as
they celebrate their mother her legacy
and her life and I think it's something
that they believe that she lived it to
the fullest to the very last moment and
there's so much to celebrate here in the
city of Houston when it comes to Barbara
Bush the city will be honoring her at a
ceremony today a memorial today that
goes on into the evening condolences
have come in from around the world from
the Queen of England even Vladimir Putin
as for the mayor he said that he's
encouraging women in this city to wear
their blue and their pearls obviously
two of the favorite things the former
first lady Vlad viana thank you very
much on one hand the nation is mourning
but we're also celebrating her legacy in
her life and her family really is
leading us leading the way you know if
there is such a thing as a beautiful
death guys it's to be 90 plus at home
holding the hand of your spouse of over
70 years and knowing that you were
beloved and still joking that's right
and dropping the one-liners to a
beautiful life bianna thank you very
much